nous sommes boulevard haussmann devant
les célèbres galeries lafayette en temps
normal est d'autant plus à cette époque
de l'année
les lieux sont bondés mais depuis la
mise en place du deuxième confinement
pour lutter contre le coronel virus
l'endroit est quasi désertique
nous allons perdre la moitié de notre
chiffre d'affaires sur l'ensemble de
l'année ce qui va entraîner des pertes
d'exploitation très significatives comme
nous n'en avions jamais enregistré
depuis 25 ans nous évaluons les pertes à
1,7 milliard d'euros lé commerce non
essentiels ont donc été obligés de
baisser les rideaux
impossible de se rendre dans une
librairie dans un restaurant dans un
magasin de vêtements ou encore chez le
coiffeur
le manque à gagner pour ces commerces
devraient atteindre 4 milliards 400
millions d'euros selon l'assureur crédit
euler hermes
et si la mesure de fermeture devait se
prolonger au cours du mois de décembre
les pertes pourraient s'établir à 10
milliards 800 millions d'euros
les quelques assouplissements accordées
par l'état
click and collect livraison à domicile
et l'adoption rapide des outils digitaux
par les commerçants ont permis de
limiter quelque peu ce manque à gagner
nous estimons qu'une fermeture complète
des commerciaux non essentiels physique
en novembre et décembre est donc une
absence totale de vente aurait engendré
un manque à gagner de 18 milliards
d'euros pour les entreprises concernées
déjà fragilisé par le premier
confinement ces commerces naissance
qu'elles ont subi un manque à gagner et
qui n'a pas été compensée par le rebond
de la demande
enregistré entre juin et septembre
dernier quand on est chef d'entreprise
on n'a plus peur de la faillite que duke
au vide pour l'instant on a gelé les
dettes
on a décalé les remboursements de
charger d'emprunt certains loyers ne
sont pas payés mais un moment tout va
s'arrêter
certaines banques n'acceptent déjà plus
de décaler les remboursements d'emprunts
on va se retrouver face à des
entreprises qui seront en défaut de
paiement
chômage partiel reports et annulations
de charges et d'impôts
une fois que les dispositifs des
d'urgence de l'état arriveront à
échéance
de nombreuses entreprises craignent de
ne pas pouvoir se relever
d'ailleurs selon l'observatoire français
des conjonctures économiques
près de cent mille sociétés devraient
disparaître d'ici la fin de l'année
entraînant dans leur sillage la
suppression de 250 mille emplois si les
indicateurs sanitaires le permettent
emmanuel macron pourrait dans son
allocution de mardi soir annoncé la
réouverture des commerces non essentiels
pour samedi prochain et pour rattraper
le temps et l'argent perdu ils
pourraient être autorisés à ouvrir tous
les dimanches de décembre
pas sûr pour autant que cette mesure
suffise à limiter la casse